three gamers in action soja dozer and
vision from the crash academy youtube
channel have agreed to go offline to
visit the berlin museum for
communication
they're checking out the no pain no gain
exhibition for euromaxx here the world
of computer games comes alive taking on
a physical dimension take the pain
station for instance players use their
right hand to play pong but every time
they make a mistake their left hand gets
punished electric shocks heat and slaps
whoever pulls their hand away first
loses it's a case of physical and
psychological warfare part of your brush
Bascom it's certainly fun and you get
really competitive despite the pain you
can't pull away because you don't want
to seem like a wimp this is a new
experience for the gamers normally they
produce let's play videos to make them
they film themselves playing and provide
a running commentary throughout stop
your tears you gave to him get in
actions before work haha this by Gooden
for locking their videos are a big hit
online thou shalt me you'll know the
true values and people watch them it's a
kind of a mix of sport and gaming you
can take part yourself and see how
others are doing steve jenkins feel
annoyed that ye also people no longer
play much themselves but they like
watching other people game it's a form
of entertainment of course it's
important for us to pack a lot of tips
tricks know how unused into our videos
and bring people on board so far packing
guard oice and annoyed ins or to
transport here even here at the
exhibition the guys find it hard not to
provide a running commentary even when
playing alone in the furminator round
two
okay let's do this
Wow the visuals are amazing this is just
one of 10 exhibits by cologne based
artist duo tillman wife and Falcon
Mojave also known as far all of their
ten installations feature an interactive
component players have to exert
themselves both physically and mentally
some of the games are even voiced
powered the bowl of auto spell other
games we build the challenge uses to
interact with a computer in a particular
way Thunder hard environment we
experiment with the different forms of
communication that exists between people
and machines commonly cancion special
mentioned mashina of unterschied alicia
advisor exactly it's a move away from
thumbs and screens it's about fistfuls
and singing Rosanna volcom Ahava until
man wife had been working together since
2001 their first collaboration the pain
station was a huge hit the unusual games
console even made it into the museum of
modern art in new york but no pain no
game is their first solo exhibition it's
supported by the German cultural
institution the goethe-institut after
touring Eastern Europe it came to
Germany the idea is to rekindle people's
passion for play
doesn't your home give us a sofa LuAnn
geared Nicky not something that somehow
gets lost children are totally open they
do everything they saying they scream
they try new things and they press every
key and they don't worry about anything
the exhibition that should be a kid
again round three it doesn't take the
game as long to find their inner child
they dive right into the snake pit a
physical take on an early cell phone
game it's all at the pecan when we'll
know soon is welcome and no it's not the
year nineteen ninety three but i think
we all played this game on our own a
nokia 6310 yes the stuff you sort of
know i'm right across from him we're
even bumping into one another my kingdom
doesn't need so what's the verdict if it
was conceived as its guile of i think is
a great concept it really challenges
players physically it's so much harder
than just playing with a joystick and
hitting a few keys gaming brought to a
whole new level
no pain no game is all about
rediscovering the joys of play a
physical challenge in a digital age
there's our girl